what's going on patrons how's everybody
doing I hope you guys are enjoying the
new poll that we did the new poll do
those options are nuts right like like
what is it it's Yoda versus Magneto it's
the force versus the power cosmic and it
is what the last one is I forgot what
the last one was ah but because you guys
voted for it last week we are covering
it this week the Green Lantern battle
royale so on this versus series we're
not going to be pitting two or three but
four characters against one another and
for this video we're focusing on Earth's
Green Lantern's Hal Jordan Guy Gardner
Jon Stewart and Kyle Rayner so to start
things off we'll briefly go over how
each of these characters came to be part
of the Green Lantern Corps then we'll go
over what powers they have as Green
Lantern's and finally decide on a winner
in this battle so Hal Jordan first
appeared in DC showcase number 22 and
1959 and was created by John Broome and
Gil Kane now when Hal debuted he
represented a major update to an
existing DC hero that bore the name of
Green Lantern the guy known as Allen
Scott that readers had largely lost
interest in now coming on the heels of a
successful reinvention of another hero
of the flash which had effectively
marked the beginning of the Silver Age
of comics DC had sought to reinvigorate
interest in the Green Lantern brand by
creating Hal Jordan to take over the
mantle of the Green Lantern and vastly
changed the entire concept of what the
Green Lantern was so House father was a
pilot killed in a plane crash while
working for a company called Ferris
aircraft now house mother forbids him
from ever flying but he defies her
wishes and enlist in the Air Force where
he quickly becomes a gifted pilot but
his military career is derailed when he
intentionally gets himself discharged by
punching a commanding officer so that he
can get home to see his estranged mother
before she dies however he does not make
it in time now after his military career
is over
how goes to work for Ferris aircraft and
while testing a flight simulator how is
transported by a mysterious field of
energy to the crash site of an alien
spacecraft where he meets a band saw a
member of the Green Lantern Corps an
intergalactic police force now avid Sur
explains that he's basically dying and
that he was in search of his successor
on earth and the power ring had
identified two worthy successors Hal
Jordan and Guy Gardner now how was
chosen because of his proximity to the
site what happens were crashed and
given the Green Lantern ring and the
power battery before leaving Earth to
train with the Green Lantern Corps on
the planet OA but once his trainings
complete how is placed in charge of
protecting sector 281 for which included
his home planet of Earth now speaking of
that gardener he was also created by Gil
Kane and John broom and made his first
appearance in green lantern number 59 in
1968 now in his original origin guide
grew up with an abusive father who used
his love of comic books as a means of
escapism but finds himself constantly
getting in trouble eventually due to the
positive influence of his older brother
guy goes to the University of Michigan
where he's the star football player and
whose career is cut short due to an
injury
now after college guy becomes a social
worker and works with troubled youths
before becoming a special education
teacher
now once Howe was selected to succeed
Evan sue as the Green Lantern of sector
to 8 1 for Guy Gardner basically served
as house back up and once howl learned
about him the two of them would
periodically go on missions together as
he completed his Green Lantern training
now when Guy Gardner is hit by a bus
rescuing a student from an earthquake
he's put out of commission for a while
so the guardians of the universe seek
out a replacement to be Hal Jordans back
up and that's where Jon Stewart comes in
now Jon Stewart was created by Dennis
O'Neil and Neal Adams and debuted in
green lantern number 87 now initially
depicted as an architect his origin was
later tweet to include the fact that he
was also a former Marine now at first
how was hesitant to accept Jon as his
backup but after their first mission
together how comes to view John as a
worthy choice and so once Hal gives up
the mantle of Green Lantern Jon Stewart
becomes a full-time Lantern a sector to
a finally we have Kyle Rayner who
debuted in Green Lantern number 48 in
1994 and was created by ron mars and
daryl banks now Kyle Rayner was a comic
book artist living in Los Angeles and
after Hal Jordan killed the rest of the
Green Lantern Corps after being
corrupted by the villainous entity
parallax Rayner was sought out by
ganthet the only member of the guardians
of the universe that how had not killed
now what's interesting about this is a
camp that doesn't really seem to think
Kyle is a particularly worthy candidate
to join the court and that in the
original issues he simply stated you'll
have to do before giving Kyle the last
remaining Green Lantern ring but it's
since been speculated that Kyle Rayner
was chosen because of his ability to
overcome fear since parallax is the
embodiment of fear now with all that in
mind we can get into the powers of the
Green Lantern's and we won't go over
each of these guys individually since
they all basically possess this
powers those afforded to them by the
Green Lantern wing but the Green Lantern
rings draw their power from the central
power battery on OA and a lot of their
wielders to gain a variety of abilities
most notably flight in the ability to
create hard light constructs that are
made of green light now these hard light
constructs variant strength directly but
the amount of willpower their wielder
possesses and the form they take is
limited only by the wielders imagination
so the question becomes this how do we
pick a winner
from a group of competitors that really
all have the same power well before we
answer that I think we need to get some
ground rules for this battle and to that
end I think we need to make it clear
that we are only considering what these
characters can do as Green Lantern's not
in any other role that they may have had
at any point in time and what I mean is
at various times Hal Jordan has been
both parallax and the specter the guy
gardner has been a Red Lantern Jon
Stewart has been an ultraviolet Lantern
Kyle Rayner has been ion and a white
Lantern and they've all been almost any
of the other Lantern course but for this
video at least we're putting all that to
the side and looking only at their
abilities as Green Lantern's and so with
that in mind I think that in order to
determine who would win in this battle
royale
we simply need to look at what each of
these guys have done during their time
as Green Lantern's and because there are
literally hundreds that we could look at
we're just gonna look at the most
impressive so starting with Jon Stewart
it's widely accepted that the hard light
constructs that he creates with his ring
are the strongest of any of the Green
Lantern's indicating that his willpower
is at an extremely high level now in one
instance when Jon is attempting to
recreate a destroyed planet he gets a
message from his ring that his level of
willpower has actually exceeded what the
ring was capable of he also survived the
destruction of a planet a black hole and
an antimatter supernova so his level of
durability is ridiculously high as well
and on one occasion Jon created an
entire platoon of green light constructs
soldiers that were capable of subduing
an entire planet of black Lantern's now
moving on the guy Gardner he is
definitely no slouch when it comes to
willpower either and in fact he's
overpowered the hard light constructs of
an opponent simply through his own
inherent willpower without even wearing
a Green Lantern ring and guy's ring has
been described as a leaky faucet with
sparks of willpower always escaping that
cannot wait to get free now guys been
able to break house constructs as well
as the constructs of other Green
Lantern's and he's been able to produce
beams of light capable of hurting
Superman who's basically invulnerable
and he
took out martian manhunter who's
involved is well in one shot
and when one instance guide creates an
elaborate construct resembling a jungle
gym that takes the combined efforts of
seven Green Lantern's including John and
how to bring down now as for Kyle Rayner
given his background as an artist he has
the most imagination of any of our
competitors
so his constructs are the most original
and take on forms that none of the
others would ever think of his willpower
is so formidable that he was able to
reverse the effects of the anti-life
equation once infected with it and
resist the corruption of parallax which
guy and John were both unable to do now
when his ring is destroyed he's able to
reform it using shards through willpower
he's able to harm a character known as
the traitor who was said to be more
powerful than Superman and even knocked
out Kalibak who's one of the new gods
now in terms of durability he survived a
blast that destroyed OA as well as a
blast from traitor that contained a more
energy than a star he survived being
frozen and being in extremely high heat
over 4000 degrees Fahrenheit without
even flinching and finally his
constructs have tanked blast from
characters such as Kalibak and Wonder
Woman and his withstood Superman's heat
vision as well and so finally we have
Hal Jordan now Hal has been able to
contain the energy of an exploding star
and has condensed the atoms of a star so
that it became solid and basically
imploded house will power is thought to
be the highest of any other Green
Lantern and it was said by volthoom the
first Lantern that half possesses more
willpower than is contained within the
central power battery itself which is
just ridiculous to think about not only
that he was able to forge a new Green
Lantern ring out of nothing but his own
willpower Howe was able to kill Crona
one of the guardians of the universe
which was thought to be impossible
because the rings were designed of being
incapable of harming any of their
creators this actually led to Howe being
kicked out of the Green Lantern Corps
due to the fear that had struck in the
hearts of the Guardians Howe was also
able to defeat Amazo
who was basically as strong as Superman
and has produced an energy blast strong
enough to destroy a planet
now after Coast cities destroyed he's
able to recreate the entirety of the
city and the people in it which leads
him to losing his ring because it
violates the rule that he cannot use it
for personal gain this makes him so
pissed off that he absorbs all the
energy from the recreated city and
travels to OA where he wipes out the
Green Lantern Corps including Sinestro
and also kills all but
one of the guardians of the universe now
if those guys who are looking at the
continuity this is the event that led
him to becoming parallax but he had not
actually yet siphoned off all the energy
of the central power battery which is
what transformed him into parallax so it
still counts as a fee that he
accomplished as only a green lantern and
so finally it's revealed in a
flash-forward that there's a book on OA
that contains all the great deeds of the
various Green Lantern's and the longest
section of that book contains stories
about Hal Jordan and that every other
Green Lantern must learn the history of
how upon completing their training and
so with all that in mind how do we
declare a winner well for this battle
we're not really going to look at power
sets because all four of these
competitors have the same powers so
we're going to have to look at their
respective strengths and weaknesses to
try and determine what their strategy is
going to be in this battle so for Jon
Stewart his real strength lies and his
attention to detail and his methodical
nature in creating his constructs which
can be attributed to both his background
as an architect as well as his military
experience gained in the Marine Corps
now his time as a Marine is likely going
to give Jon an edge in terms of battle
strategy and tactics as well which
combined with the strength of his
constructs will make him very formidable
in this battle and I think that he would
start out by developing a strategy and
waiting for the right moment to make his
first move now as for Guy Gardner there
really is nothing in my opinion that's
going to give him an advantage over any
of the other Green Lantern's in this
battle I'm sorry guy Gardner fans in
fact I think he would only really employ
the exact opposite strategies that John
does and simply go in guns blazing now
the reason I say this is the guy has
often been depicted as a bit of a
hothead and he seems to have a bit of an
inferiority complex when he compares
himself to the other Green Lantern's and
so for that reason I think he's going to
have a deep desire to prove himself
early on in this battle and this is
actually going to work to his
disadvantage during the blackest night
event guy was actually given a Red
Lantern rain due to his predisposition
to rage and since he won't have a Red
Lantern Ranger in this battle his anger
is only going to serve to lead him to
rash decision making and I believe he
would spread himself too thin too early
in the battle which would prove to be
his undoing
now Kyle waders primary strength is
going to be his creativity which is
going to lead him to creating some
pretty unorthodox constructs that the
other Green Lantern's will likely be
unable to expect and will present a
challenge for them
to figure out how to deal with now I
think that this would present an
interesting contrast to John's more
technical approach to his constructs and
it would really be a question of what's
going to win out meticulous attention to
detail and technical sophistication or
an abundance of creativity that pushes
the boundaries of the human imagination
and so finally house constructs are
neither overly technical or imaginative
but instead focus on the most simple and
practical solutions to a problem now how
has never been regarded as overly flashy
when it comes to the constructs he
employs but its primary strength lies
and his abundance of willpower that
based off the feats that we've seen him
do seems to eclipse any of the other
Green Lantern's in this battle and
perhaps any other Green Lantern period
so how I see this battle playing out guy
will just go in guns blazing with
everything he has at the start of the
battle without too much of a plan which
when dealing with other lanterns that
have as much experience is how Kyle and
John will not be a good plan and he
likely would find himself being the
first eliminated from this battle now I
think John and Kyle's construct styles
are going to make for an interesting
conflict with John probably focusing on
creating constructs that resemble
traditional weaponry and machines of war
while Kyle would use his imagination to
create something completely out of left
field like some kind of mythological
creature or an army of superheroes I
mean I don't really know what it would
be but like most of the constructs it
would be both awesome and absurd now
between the two of them I would
ultimately give the nod to Kyle as his
constructs are so creative and outside
of the box that even with all of his
military training and meticulous
planning John would not likely be able
to plan an adequate defense for them but
I think that at the end of the day this
battle is going to end with Hal Jordan
emerging as the ultimate Victor when it
comes right down to it once prowess as a
green lantern is basically measured by
the amount of willpower they possess and
while all four of these guys have low
power in abundance none of them can
rival the amount that how has and while
I don't think that this would be a walk
in the park for Hal by any means he is
regarded as the greatest of the Green
Lantern's for a reason he has more
willpower and more experience as a Green
Lantern than any of his opponents and
he'd be able to use his constructs more
effectively than any of his opponents
and for those reasons I think that he
wins this battle here with Kyle likely
finishing in second by a narrow margin
over John and guy being the least
successful of the four
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end let me know
what you all think down in the comments
of this thank you for being patrons I
love you guys to death and I will see
you all next week
[Music]